il ya la rumeur de la semaine qui est
sorti on a un peu parlé ah oui c'est une
téléréalité miss france en préparation
autre mardi mais il va laisser les pros
en parler il y aurait une guerre guerre
de deux femmes ayant une guerre entre
alexia laroche joubert et s'éviter liés
à l'excès a repris redex en miss france
et elle voudrait
moderniser le set l'événement en lan
dans le télé réalisant est ce vrai faux
à les y former alors moi j'ai eu cette
semaine longuement alexis allart jouer
l'oiseau un très gros melon et non mais
elle a été très cash très clair il en
est absolument hors de question elle ne
veut absolument pas en faire une
téléréalité pour elle c'est une rumeur
qui part d'un bouquin qui est sorti à
quelques années puis qui a été monté un
petit peu en épingle donc elle est pas
du tout d'accord elle la seule chose
qu'elle a faite qui est peut-être un
tout petit peu dans ce sens là c'est
d'avoir changé un petit peu les
portraits des mises c'est à dire que par
exemple c'est elle qui présentent leur
région c'est elle qui se présente un cas
un peu comme les petites plastique on
pouvait voir dans les télés révélé m en
7 étapes comment les mettre en scène
donc elle mais si oui déjà fait lors de
la dernière dernières élections c'est à
dire qu'on les voit dans leur région et
présenter leurs miroirs etc machin truc
mais il y aura absolument pas de télé
réalité telle que tu les connais par
coeur qui seront qui seront mises en
hommes étudiés pour miss france alors
quid de sylvie tellier la rumeur dit
qu'elle va prendre la direction de la
star à gaz et la mcit nouvelle formule
visiblement c'est complète sa jambe ou
alors elle est bien partie elle a fait
ses petits cartons elle est allée elle
est vraiment partie des bureaux de là
bas mais par contre comme par hasard ce
serait peut-être la première année on
verrai une miss transgenres qui serait
miss ile de france qui s'appelle andrea
furet et qui représenteraient du coup du
coup à l'île de france à aux crochets
nous faut qu'elle soit élue en fait elle
va se présenter à miss paris et bien il
est pas élu ça arrive qu'on s'est vite
taillé 120 c'est vrai qu'il faut
modifier les statuts de miss france je
pense qu'elle fait en cinq à vingt mois
d'avancé le concours à andré abri qui
est une vraie transgenres 4d déjà vu
qu'on a vue de plusieurs téléfilms et
notamment mercredi soir sur l'a2 dans
une fiction qui s'appelait la faute à
rousseau dans telle est l'une des
héroïnes ne s'est pas vraiment quelqu'un
qui
l'un des critères c'est notamment de ne
pas avoir recours à la chirurgie
esthétique oui mais oui c'est vrai que
c'est un fait représenté dans son parler
franc ça va être changé oui
c'est la chirurgie reconstructive diagne
à la poitrine
pas être considérée dans une transition
la vaginoplastie et la petit des
implants mammaires peuvent être
considérés comme réparatrice c'est juste
le visage ou au fait où il ne faut pas
avoir de chirurgie et de toute façon on
en est encore loin pour l'instant parce
qu'andrea furet est en finale de miss
paris est encore du chemin avant qu'aso
y voit là il n'y est pas encore mais
elle le mériterait elle est très jolie
très jeune mais déjà très connu et
valence l'a déjà dit ce que la bouche ce
n'est pas déjà fait un petit peu non
les
jolies aller très vite et c'est moins
sur la photo 1 avec quand même juste
parce que c'est important c'est vraiment
c'était l'un des critères qui
différencie les miss franc et avec le
reste du monde absolument mais universal
qui avait pas de recours à aucune
chirugie hmm hmm hmm légère mais marx
lassé de la médecine esthétique déjà on
n'est pas dans la chirurgie esthétique
atteint est ce que vous pensez
est ce qu'on doit aujourd'hui dans le
dans la mouvance de moderniser ce ce
concours autorisé la médecine esthétique
mais oui je m'en fous d'un côté je vous
ai rangé pardon je rappellerai à une
prochaine personnellement je suis contre
à pourquoi je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que les miss en général elles ont
pratiquement entre 18 et 21 ans à son
très jeune donc l ont pas spécialement
besoin en règle générale la chirurgie
esthétique donc pour moi ça fausse un
petit peu les débats sa fausse un peu la
réalité et ça fausse à peler les
arrivées que c'est pas un peu fort
avec la
classe je suis gonflé les lèvres non
mais tu peux le faire à 50 ans
commandant mais pourquoi changer les
règles mais je
l'évolué mois est à peu près 7 millions
et demi de téléspectateurs
les gens regardent ils soient ils sont
attirés par miss france draine pourquoi
du jour au lendemain changer la donne
pourquoi changer d'échelle asus est
révolu
où les règles sont faites pour être
changé de nom mais honnêtement ce n'est
pas d'aujourd'hui citerai des limbes le
concours de miss univers miss monde les
filles sont très jolies et ainsi ses 99
ans bientôt enfin quelques exemples tout
refaire des choses ben c'est pas voilà
et les penchants rectifiant série peut
s'inscrire pour voter c'est pas là c'est
pas la femme c'est pas mal on n'est dupe
à marianne
d'autant que changer pour être plus
jolie pour s'améliorer dit moi je trouve
anormal qu'on ne sait pas pourquoi je
fais justement est bien là dessus c'est
paolo woods a on arrive non trafic et
moi je dois bien
c'est différent c'est un vrai cas
d'école est ce qu'il faut est ce que
transgenres il faut un concours à part
oui si vous voulez
c'est pas un débat parce que les femmes
transgenres sont vraiment considérés
comme des cages d'escaliers
une chose une dernière chose il ya
exactement à peu près le même problème
dans le milieu du sport sportif je vous
dire c'est étrange en flammes et c'est
sa fausse un peu les débats parce qu'une
un homme qui devient femme et qui se
permet de jouer dans une équipe féminine
mais tu consacres
forêts pcf a besoin
ou vers la pop ce que c'est compliqué de
dire effectué aujourd'hui et des
sportifs qui pourront aller jouer avec
les femmes et vice versa ça a été fait
dans le rugby donc cesser saab c'est
plus un problème il faudrait que le
gabarit le regard encore elle
même ce soir atterrissent chez les
abeilles armand vaquerin les amis mais
bon on
n'attendait plus